this is a production of Cornell
University
good evening everyone I'm Mike Hoffman
one
associate Dean's in the College of Ag
and life sciences and director of the
Cornell University agricultural
experiment station the one in Ithaca and
welcome you to tonight's panel
conversation discussion title of the
program is facing adversity farming
through unpredictability also known as
climate change that's a real pleasure to
have some esteemed guests on the panel
tonight on this they will I'll just
introduce them by name now later on
they'll provide more information about
their farm and background but Paul verse
cabbage Jenny Chris and Alison shaktra
cam so my task is to provide a
background sort of a overview of the
topic and with that oh I'd like to
acknowledge to people before we get
started and that's Jennifer Benson and
Sharon deets are both from cows alumni
affairs and development for helping
organize all this and get you all here
so let me provide a backdrop to this
topic let's start with the basics
climate change just imagine the
atmosphere is a blanket and it's just
the right thickness it's been that way
for thousands of years to retain you
have high energy sunlight coming in
reflected off the earth at a lower
energy it bounces back and forth just
like in a greenhouse so that blanket has
been optimal at about 270 parts per
million of carbon dioxide for thousands
of years and that's why we have
agriculture that's why civilization is
flourished so keep that concept of a
blanket in mind and things are changing
if you look at the graphs on the right
those are graphs of the three primary
greenhouse gases carbon dioxide on the
top methane and nitrous oxide and again
that 270 parts per million is a good
thing is kept everything just where we
need it to be to be where we are today
as a civilization however in 2012 we hit
390
parts per million as a forty percent
increase in that concentration of carbon
dioxide and that blanket is getting
thicker therefore things are heating up
the Sun the energy is not radiating back
up this concept of greenhouse gases
several people in the 1800's one guy by
the name of Jack Tyndall came up with
this concept it's pretty straightforward
he was he was my buddy in high school
track it was fun but looking forward to
the year 2100 it is likely we're going
to have 900 parts per million by that
time and then if you look at the scale
where that trajectory just imagine right
now at the top chart it says 360 but
that would go to 900 that's hard to
grasp but that's the direction we are
headed as business as usual without
making any major changes in how we
operate some facts global average
temperatures are increasing one and a
half degrees since the Industrial
Revolution it's getting warmer at the
poles generally warming twice as fast as
near the equator and it's not uniform
Alaska has warmed about 7 degrees
Western Antarctic about 10 degrees the
hottest decade ever ever was 2000 1 to
10 last year in the u.s. it was the
hottest year ever recorded and we
exceeded previous records by one degree
Fahrenheit summers are warmer and longer
winters warmer and again business as
usual we are likely to hit eight degrees
Fahrenheit increase by 2100 just to put
it in perspective the last ice age was
eight degrees colder the evidence is all
around us in the middle if I'm sure
you've heard about this summer loss of
Arctic sea ice it's reduced about forty
percent from historical records and if
you think that an area that's about the
equivalent of half of the continental US
which has always been reflective because
it's totally white now it's deep blue
ocean and can absorb heat there's a bit
of a feed Mac man
anism potential layer on the right
glaciers are retreating pretty much
universally around the world why is that
important hydroelectric power forty
percent of Bolivia's hydroelectric power
comes from melting glaciers for example
in irrigation water the oceans
lower-left are rising just an eighth of
an inch a year doesn't sound like much
most of the much good part of that is
simply water expands when it warms the
oceans are warming the waters expanding
the balance of that are a good portion
of it is coming from more from the
melting glaciers and lastly upper left
anybody hiked been in Colorado in the
last two three four years in the
mountains well I'm an entomologist and i
thought this was amazing because you'll
know that's a photograph I took but a
good portion of the trees are dead the
reason being long-term drought warmer
winters warmer summers and bark beetles
love it and the scale of that is amazing
it encompasses about 78,000 square miles
from the southern tip of the Rockies up
into British Columbian British Columbia
there's where there are no trees left
for all dead okay kind of a global
picture we're going to bring it down to
the state so we have challenges more
extreme weather floods droughts high
temperature stress new pests hey things
are cool the southern insects are going
again I'm an animala gist job security
well we'll have new invasive species and
basically getting less predictable
there's more variability on the other
hand we have some opportunities we will
have water in this part of the country
longer seasons warmer seasons what can
we do with that and if you look around
the world around just in the u.s. other
parts of the country are going to be
under greater stress agriculture in
California for example the precipitation
patterns in the Sierra is shifting
towards more rain during the winter
instead of snow so there's no banking
never reservoir of water to tap during
the summer and then throw in San
Francisco Los Angeles and a lot of
competition for that water but again it
positions us here a little kind of on
the upside recently well the scale of
this is from 1872 now each of those
fires represents a decade and you can
see an increase and heat stress they
degree days over 90 degrees Fahrenheit
and likewise the right side increase in
heavy rains this is two inches in 24
hours the bar on the far right is 2010
so lots of challenges but then back to
the opportunities potential to expand
the diversify agriculture new crops new
varieties winter canola were growing at
northern New York for first nineteen
nineteen ninety you could not do that
California grape industry is suffering
especially in San Joaquin Valley because
of the high temperatures are getting too
high sugar content on the other hand
this opens up opportunities for us
double cropping and we have markets
thirty percent of the u.s. populations
out here in this part of the country and
can we market this local grown lower
carbon footprint produce good for job
creation economic development but what
we need to adapt better decision tools
for our producers when does it make
sense to put additional cooling in a
dairy facility because hot cows produce
less milk when should I switch to a new
crop water management is going to be a
big deal either too much or not enough
so when do I put in additional tiling
window i buy irrigation equipment and
there's communication strategies among
farmers educators and researchers and
clearly communicating to policymakers
there's adaptation to these changes but
then we can't forget about mitigation
which is reducing our carbon
contribution to the atmosphere
greenhouse gas emissions so on farm
increased energy efficiencies II using
less fossil fuel waste conversion to
heat anaerobic digestion reduced tillage
cover crops and improve nutrient
management are all ways to mitigate the
impact of agriculture on climate change
so trying to pulling some of this
together the summary more uncertainty
more risk in the future there's
opportunities to mitigate and adapt
agriculture in New York state is
positioned to expand and diversify and
we have the capacity around at our
farmer community Cooperative Extension
Cornell other institutions and as you
will hear from our panelists farmer
on it they're researchers they're making
decisions every day on new variety so
we're going to hear from both both of
the producers on what they're doing to
adapt and lastly there are activities in
response to this there's new initiatives
across the state at Cornell I've been
involved for two years in a joint effort
with Canadians correctly to the north
that somehow climate change and
international borders there it's
insignificant so they're looking to see
what opportunities they have by the way
75 for their population lives in eastern
Canada they've got incredible markets we
recently started this Institute for
climate change in agriculture Cornell
there's some new reports out and clearly
Cooperative Extension as Allison will
describe is a resource and again I'll
turn back to our own producers as a
resource of new information so with that
turn to the panel I think Jenny's going
first and we're going to if you don't
mind we'll hold questions until the end
hello my name is Jenny crist and I I
work with my parents on our apple
orchard in the Hudson Valley it's does
that sound about right okay it's a it's
about 600 acres and we we actually have
about eight different non-contiguous
locations some are closer or farther
away from the Hudson River and they have
varying altitudes also and so we get to
observe some of the different climatic
impacts but anyways I I sort of
categorized some of the different ways
that the changing climate affects us via
earlier Springs hotter summers milder
winters a longer growing season and more
severe storms so I'll just go through
each of those things so earlier Springs
there's been a lot of press about the
the frost and how it damaged the apple
crop this year
there's different ways that damage the
crop you can see the the those apples
are actually dead they're brown inside
those are the baby apples but then there
can be scarring the quality issues on
apples that are actually you know reach
harvest maturity and that's all because
you know the apples are much more prone
to frost once they're at a susceptible
stage so if the springs are earlier
because we have a mild winter and this
past winter we started seeing spring in
March then the the apples reach a
susceptible stage much earlier in the
year and were more more more prone to
the cold weather and actually dr. art de
gaetano has done some research about the
the killing frost that have been
occurring and he's predicting that the
the frost risk is going to increase
through time and there's probably going
to be we categorize it by ten percent
kill or fifty percent kill or ninety
percent kill of the apples but there's
probably going to be about the same
number of ten percent kills but more 50
and ninety percent kills just because of
the variability of the weather so so
anyways Ryan and I on the way up we're
trying to figure out the Ryan's are firm
credit loan officer we were trying to
figure out the difference in yield
between a good site and a poor site and
how much extra you could afford to pay
for a good site / app or site to prevent
against frost and so he's very
interesting this year we actually we we
could really see the difference in a
good site and app or site a good site
had pretty much a full crop like maybe a
thousand bushel per acre and a poor site
could have so little that we didn't even
bother to pick it so almost zero but
anyways we we averaged like 500 or
upon a bushel per acre difference and if
you take an average market price in a
good year when there's a short crop of
fourteen dollars per bushel and then
take out your variable costs so do a
30-percent gross margin that's about
twenty one hundred dollars just for the
difference in yield not even counting
the difference in quality and that's
really interesting because when you go
to purchase a new site you might want to
take that into consideration as far as
what you're going to what you're willing
to buy an acre for and what you're
planning to grow because the frost event
won't occur every year but if it occurs
once every 10 years or if it occurs you
know twice in 20 you might want to
figure that in the 2100 dollars and then
you can add the quality contribution on
top of that too there's some more
examples of hilltop sites in the Hudson
Valley planting on the hills the other
thing we do for for frost before I get
to the summer part once you know when
there is a frost coming we we have a
wind machine we've also tried out some
helicopters the helicopters are are
really hard to manage it's a less
consistent result and you have to work
closely with the pilot my dad had a lot
of fun with them in the middle of the
night last one last spring but it's very
expensive it can be three hundred
dollars to a thousand dollars per hour
being on standby can cost a lot of money
and then you really need to we had them
work up the hill so as it got colder
three nights in a row in late April they
moved up the hill to cover the higher
and higher ground as we gave up on the
lower ground but in the end it was
really hard to measure the benefit that
they did or didn't give and we were
frustrated with our ability to get the
helicopter right where we wanted it we
would have preferred to drive it
ourselves but um the the wind machines
are more consistent result and we can
see the difference between areas that we
didn't didn't have the wind machine at
similar elevations and they cost about
30 24
forty thousand dollars to install and
they can maybe protect about 10 acres
but then they also require a significant
amount of fuel but those are becoming
more techie which is interesting you
know you can have them come on
automatically when it reaches a certain
temperature and things like that if you
get the newer the newer kind so those
are some different things some different
options to consider and it of course it
all depends on the specifics of the
night about whether the there's an
inversion because if there's no warm air
up above it doesn't help too much but
and then there's also the consideration
about crop insurance if you first of all
we think it's a really important thing
to buy crop insurance but then there's a
you know the different levels you can
choose and if you have crop insurance
you're the amount you're willing to
invest in a helicopter or in a wind
machine is probably a little less than
if you didn't have crop insurance and
Ryan and I tried to figure out what that
level was too but it's really tricky so
because there's a 50-percent deductible
on the crop insurance and so it gets
really hard to figure but it'd be easier
if you knew exactly what temperature was
going to be that night and exactly what
impact that would have on the crop but
then so how'd our summers as Mike was
saying you know we're health we have
longer hot spells the heat waves are
more intense and more frequent and
increased frequency of drought I had to
make sure my dad wasn't gonna be too
embarrassed if I showed these pictures
this is raw on honey crisp and it's it's
caused probably buy a few things but
especially by sunburn which allows the
rot spores to get in it damages the
surface of the Apple and kind of cooks
it but that can be aggravated by a lack
of water also and actually the surface
temperature of the apple can be 30
degrees higher on hot days than the air
temperature so if it's a hundred degrees
out surface of the Apple can be 130
degrees and so that that's a lot of
stress especially on this delicate
variety but we've also only been growing
for about 10 years so it's not something
we've seen a big change in over the
course of the climate change discussion
but it is something we factor in with
the the warmer summers so one thing that
we do is you know a lot of drip
irrigation just to relieve the stress on
the trees because you can see that the
high-density plantings that were
transitioning to and at the Apple world
this is a second leaf tree on the tall
spindle Terrance robinson's new planting
style from Cornell and so they those
trees were planted the previous growing
season and you can see the apples on
them which is pretty amazing and there's
a drip line in there but there's not a
huge root system and those little trees
are already producing fruit and so they
really they really need the support of
the water to grow the tree and also to
grow the apples and there's a lot of
research that the more the the more
stress there is on the tree the more
stress there will be on the fruit and
the lesser the the quality of the fruit
in the yield that's another blocked up
that block is older probably like five
or six years old and you can see there's
there's just not a lot of tree structure
therefore the amount of fruit and so you
really have to keep the water applied so
the other thing that's interesting you
can irrigate of course overhead for for
frost frost control for his control and
in Washington they also overhead
irrigate they do evaporative cooling to
cool down the fruit and prevent loss of
water in the orchard on the hot days so
we're thinking of trying something like
that on our honey crest but on a high
value crop of course honey crisp sold
this year for like eighty dollars a
bushel and a normal year a good bin of
cider apples is like ninety dollars for
you know a whole bin but honey crisp or
a high value high value crop
we're also with the hot summers
experiencing with our experimenting with
some Sun protectants they're mostly
calcium-based it's kind of like a
sunscreen on the Apple I don't have any
pictures of that but you just have to be
really careful that it will wash off and
it can also impact color development on
the Apple we've tried it on a lot of
Honey Crisp and some of the color hasn't
developed quite the same but it needs to
wash off otherwise it looks like the
Apple has spray all over even though
it's just calcium it's not very
appealing to the consumer anyways the
the milder winters is the the next next
thing and I guess the the milder winters
impact us a little bit less there on
average four degrees warmer than the 70s
according to Cornell we do have to wait
a little bit longer for the trees to
harden off if we start with a milder
winter before we start pruning this year
and last year we waited at least a month
longer before we started our serious
pruning because if you make a big wound
in the tree before it's hardened off you
can get winter injury when it cools down
also the milder winters can encourage
the deer population this is our new deer
fence we put in last winter it's 8 feet
tall we saw a deer jump over an 8 foot
tall fence so don't do a six foot tall
one um if you're going to do it but it
costs about fifteen thousand dollars a
mile we did seven miles of it and we
figured out based on the area that was
enclosed it was about six hundred
dollars an acre but it can impact
production like by about twenty-five
percent we have a farm that's had a deer
fence for a number of years and we just
saw the production climb up and up in
the years after the deer fence was
installed so we're pretty big believers
now four of our locations have deer
fences in the return on investment for a
deer fence so this is one of the nice
things about climate change we have a
longer growing season and we never
thought we could grow pink ladies before
but weekend so these are in their third
leaf I think and we we have beautiful
pink
the one thing that we've experienced
with them is because of longer growing
season the insects have more time to get
to them and you have to end the summer
disease and you have to protect those
apples longer some insects can have a
third generation that didn't use to have
a third generation as you have a longer
growing season so we have to keep
staying on top of that we also 20 years
ago we never thought we'd grow Fugees
but we've been Fugees are actually
harvested before pink ladies so they're
a no-brainer now but as it gets warmer
they can grow them more in western New
York and other areas farther north so um
and then the last thing um these are I I
believe more severe storms are
associated with climate change and I'm
not sure if that necessarily means hail
but there is more rain and more wind and
this is what can happen if your trellis
system isn't good enough on a hill and
then my dad ends up doing that as long
as the tree can be salvaged but one
thing we've learned is with you know as
we switch to these higher density
plantings that we really need a a
stronger trellis system that will hold
that kind of weight especially when we
get these high these high wind storms
and the soggy ground and the shallow
root system on a big hill like I showed
you at the beginning so we really have
to build for that one of our Jamaican
guys told us we weren't thinking very
much when we set these up and then hail
of course I'm not sure if that's
particularly associated with climate
change but it tends to come with strong
storms sometimes and there's not an
awful lot we can do about that
unfortunately except to diversify our
locations that's one reason we have so
many different locations and we're
spread out it might be more convenient
to be on one spot but it diversifies the
risk a little bit and then the the crop
insurance is really really really
important when it comes
to hail so in summary I guess the most
important thing is to invest wisely in
your sights for elevation and air
drainage but also for water because as
we you know have bigger longer droughts
or hotter summers and want to use
evaporative cooling we need to have the
water available and really think through
carefully it might sound like a big
number per acre that you would would
have to invest have the nicer site but
it might be worth it especially looking
at climate change and if you can
diversify in location to spread your
risk that's also very important for
severe storms and then invest wisely in
your plantings to choose the the site
carefully to match match the variety so
like we put our pink ladies on the
southern facing slope on this farm
farthest to the south and we put our
honey crisp that suffer from the the
heat we put them on the north-facing
slope on the farm farthest to the north
so between choosing the varieties that
the market once and then placing them
carefully on your different locations to
have the best the best return it's
really important at it ten thousand
dollars or more per acre by the time you
set it all up you can't afford to make a
lot of mistakes planting by crop
insurance and then carefully consider
the defrost control measures and in the
end I mean a lot of the things that I
talked about with the climate change
their good management practices in
general and things that farmers have
been doing for a while we may need to do
them more frequently now or to a larger
a greater degree but I just wanted to
point out that climate change it's a
risk that we face we're dealing with it
step by step it's a gradual change but
there's a lot of other risks that factor
into business management you know one of
our biggest business risk right now is
having an affordable and legal labor
force and willing labor force and then
you know it's great we have Cornell and
extension we and they help us through
you know these climate change issues and
the Hudson Valley lab is there for us
every every spring when we're
confronting things like the frost and
giving us the heads-up button on
everything but they send daily emails
and are always available but the
research on the stinkbug and some of the
different insects and the extended life
cycles of the insects is really
important so we're we're glad that
Cornell's there for us so that's it I'll
pass it on to pop okay yeah my name is a
pause kovitch I'm a fourth generation
onion growers from Orange County New
York I farm in partnership with my
father and you know thinking about you
know different weather patterns and
farming through unpredictability I
thought I'd just share some of the
experiences that we've had over the last
two years because weather has certainly
had an impact in our area not so much
for the good so I think I'll start off
well back up a little bit I mention I'm
an onion grower that's primarily what
historically what we've grown however
two years ago we started growing some
winter squash and pumpkins and we've
grown some corn and soybeans on and off
over two years so anyway I'm gonna start
with the last season 2011 last season
was an extremely what year right from
the beginning it seemed like we were
fighting the wet all season long we had
some onions that we planted it was so
wet they rotted we ripped them up we
planted squash and all season long
stayed wet and then of course that was
ended in august by hurricane irene and
tropical storm lee where we had eight to
nine inches of rain in less than 24
hours and with the soil already being
saturated of course we flooded on our
farm we lost about eighty-five percent
of the crowd
up dollar value somewhere around 300,000
so need to say it was a pretty hard hit
there were some growers in Valley who
lost their entire crop so one one
advantage that i did have last year is i
planted about eight acres of squash and
upland outside of the muck so of course
i didn't flood and that was the only
squash ended up selling last year so as
a result this past summer 2012 did grow
some more squash no plan we had
approximately 20 acres and of course
that presents other challenges with
wildlife you know Jenny much in
challenges with deer we had deer and
woodchucks which did quite a bit of
damage on I had 14 acre field is the
poor location because right next to it
was our neighbor and dairy farm he had
his his bunk silo so the deer would go
to the heat some silage and they come
into the squash field and then he went
down a hill and author muck and a
pumpkin so any i won't i won't be
growing up field next year but anyway
this growing season was actually a
fairly decent growing season and started
off a little on the dry side but we were
able to get an early start it was a good
growing season until we got to the fall
and this fall was extremely wet which
resulted in serious quality issues in
our onions seems the the first onions we
harvested were very good but anything
harvested after a certain date just sort
of broke down and we had a lot of waste
and not only that but the weather stayed
wet for so long we didn't have any good
drying air to to help dry the crop so
that contributed to it also this year
was squash we did have an early frost
and very hard frost and early October
so i probably lost about 12 acres of
butternut squash so many other squash
was a little hard to hear so that was
all right but we did have a lot of
problems harvesting just because of wet
weather not only because of the weather
but we were also faced with a labor
shortage I know it's tougher on the
state but particularly in Orange County
we had a difficult time getting labor in
a fall to pick so you know normally I
can line up day cruise come pick squash
was ready to be picked but this year I
had a hard time finding day cruise and
then days when I could get a crew and
ended up raining and couldn't pick so
that was a challenge and looking back
you know some of the quality issues we
had with onions I think a lot of that
stems from last year with the flooding
any time you have a flood you have all
kinds of bacteria and other pathogens
come in with the floodwaters and on top
of that we had a very mild winter last
last winter so things didn't freeze to
kill a lot of the pathogens as you
normally would have if you had a nice
nice heart free so this one arm we've
had some cold weather I'm hoping we get
some more so anyway thinking ahead to
next year I'm going to be cutting back
someone squash I'm not so much worried
about the weather azam about labor with
a squash because you know you can grow
it but if you can't get it picked it
doesn't do you any good I'm also going
to be growing some more corn and
soybeans one thing I've noticed you know
you talk about warming temperatures and
opportunities for new crops I'd say you
know ten years ago you probably saw a
very few if any soybeans grown in Orange
County I know just this past summer
there's been at least two grain bins
that have gone up around the county so
there's quite a few more acres of
soybeans being grown and I will also
continue to grow someone upland
although not as much and sort of to
summarize things you know thinking about
you know severe weather patterns and
just farming through unpredictability I
think you know whether you're dealing
with climate change or not mother nature
is always going to throw you a curveball
even in a normal year or whatever that
is anymore and so I think it's you know
one thing I've learned it's good to be
at least a little bit diversified so
that you can spread your risk out over
more than one crop when you have all
your eggs in one basket particularly
with a high value or a crop like onions
where you have pretty high input costs
it's good to diversify a little bit and
also I think in general just need to be
willing and able to adapt to change
particularly to unpredictable events
whether it be weather-related or
regulatory or or whatever so that I
think I'll plenty thank you
well good evening my name is Allison
catheter john and i'm from Dutchess
County Cooperative Extension and I think
we're gonna pull up my talk here great
thank you so thank you for having me
here um is there this is the clicker yes
so I thought I'd start off with a short
video and I might have to hit the so
I've been very fortunate to be working
half time for the last almost two years
on a new initiative that we're very
fortunate that Helene Delores is a
production of Cornell University can we
okay so I've been working on a new
statewide Cooperative Extension team and
this um is providing halftime funding
for five educators around the state we
have someone working on agriculture
specifically Mary reggae in Oneida
County my focus on is on climate change
and so I've been working with cornell
university faculty to develop new
outreach materials on climate change to
bring them out to our extension
audiences and so this is one of the new
mechanisms that we're using to reach out
to farmers and i'm only going to show a
little bit this is a production of
Cornell University we've been very lucky
on Fishkill farms not to have any severe
effects from the big storms of last year
but our neighbors have certainly had a
lot of trouble across the river in hasta
county there was tremendous damage and
it's not only from the Irene storm and
hurricanes it was also there been wind
and hail events throughout the last
couple of years that have periodically
caused of course to have in store walls
and the October snow storm knocked over
a lot of trees as well so and broke a
lot of branches so yes sir there have
been quite a few events that are quite
severe and we're seeing you know big
swings on the the rainfall side as well
between drought and prolonged periods of
extreme extremely heavy rainfall that
just gives you a brief overview and we
did hear from jetty and she's a similar
fruit orchard farmer in the Hudson
Valley the reason I showed that is that
we're just starting new ways of reaching
out to farmers and doing some of these
short video clips that will be posting
on climate change website at Cornell so
I think it's important to keep this nifa
priority in mind that as we see a
changing climate we need to help our
agricultural system help our farmers
adapt to a changing climate while
maintaining their economic vitality and
so that's what our program work team is
doing at Cornell and our statewide team
and so I think it's also interesting
there was a recent study of farmers done
at Iowa State University it could be
possible to do a similar study of
attitudes of farmers in New York State
to really understand scientifically what
their knowledge is of climate change and
in Iowa actually sixty-six percent of
farmers indicate they believe climate
change is occurring however only eight
percent believe it's caused by humans
thirty-five percent believe it's equally
caused by humans and natural causes
twenty-five percent due to natural
causes so really while it is positive
that sixty-six percent of farmers
believe that climate change is occurring
now we do still have some work to do in
our communication in our outreach and
providing the research that's taking
place at Cornell out to the stakeholders
that we work with and so I mentioned our
new statewide energy and climate change
team I would encourage you to contact
your local edge
leaders in your local office talk to
your cooperative extension boards boards
of directors and your agricultural
agents see if they've gone through
training and if you have questions about
extreme weather events they can
certainly contact our team or where
contact researchers are Cornell I've
been working with what I mentioned is a
program work team on climate change and
this really is just a mechanism where
faculty our staff and our extension
educators can come together usually in
person twice a year and then we have
communications and other work teams that
are working on committees and this
allows us to better communicate to each
other about research about funding
opportunities we recently submitted an
EPA environmental education grant that
will provide a funded climate change
education for several different enrolled
volunteer programs including Master
Gardeners so we hope that kind of
collaboration will help bring more
funding to cooperative extension into
Cornell researchers and I mentioned that
where we have been working on new
communications outreach we've been at
Empire farm days at the New York State
Fair we been at fairs like the Dutchess
County Fair I did a similar talk for our
agricultural breakfast where we had a
hundred people in the room to talk about
extreme weather and I think you're going
to see an increase in this type of
communication from Cooperative Extension
and so I'll end with some win-win
benefits that I think both of our
producers talked about that really
taking on some of this work to start
thinking about climate change is good
for farmers because it can reduce risks
and help prepare for extreme weather you
can take advantage of the opportunities
that Michael mentioned you can improve
your operations and upgrade
infrastructure and there several
incentive
programs for New York farmers through
nice sorta and you can contact
Cooperative Extension if you're have
questions about that we can help promote
local sustainable economic growth
through local food systems biofuels and
production agriculture here in New York
and help support our communities and
become more sustainable in upstate New
York and throughout New York State and
with that this is a production of
Cornell University have you seen any
local effects of extreme weather and
climate change in the years especially
bit especially because you your native
you to Dutchess County ah yes i have it
seems like the winners are getting much
milder we're getting more i think more
severe weather as we head south seems
the beginning more snow more cold
winners are not nearly as bad we've had
three major weather events in the last
couple of years 12 years ago the
obsessive snow throughout the winter
last fall with the you know being hit by
tremendous amounts of rain hurricane and
then this winter with I don't ever
recall winner of this as easy as it was
I've gone through snowless winners but
never with this mild as it's been we
didn't have the leader actually and we
didn't have a winner and I see a lot
less hey was fed a lot less hey was used
which is you know don't allege sort it's
good for those that didn't have to buy
had it but it's more for those of us
that sell high or it's an issue what the
insect population
the bad bugs that were killed in today's
paper was a major thing about Lyme
disease beings you know perhaps the
banner year for Len disease so I'm
really concerned over what's coming down
the road even though i can predict i can
only hope things won't be as dyers by
maybe what happened to your farm during
the extreme weather events and how much
money you think you lost how did it
affect you ah curse it started in April
last year with the fact that we had so
much trouble getting the crops in just
you know we got them seated we couldn't
go and go back and roll them roll them
and pick up rock which in turn we
probably got a poor or catch a seed than
we should have so that that bothered us
you know just little little things that
you know don't always add up the fact
that you have to send people again and
again back to the field because there's
big wet spot she and go around and stuff
like that takes a lot more time we lost
probably half hour old crop because we
couldn't get it we couldn't her sit in
the window that we had he went down we
lost a lot of it the biggest thing
that's bothering me right today is that
we left probably fifteen thousand
dollars worth of hay second cutting
grass hay in the field that we could not
harvest last fall we made many attempts
we got some in but we knew a lot of hay
so we we left fifteen thousand dollars
with a hey of the field which is really
financially bothering me right now
strapping me we lost the field of corn
that was you know a lot of it was
management fault for not chopping that
field we left it for grain thought we
could get it and we got the late snow
storm and it was very talk learning it
took it down so we lost we lost a lot of
corn over there so we probably lost a
minimum of forty thousand or solid crops
you can s farm you can you can weather
the storm but you can't weather
continuous storms you can you can take
it on the chin you can you know you you
come back spring brings eternal hope and
that's as a farmer that's what's that's
what fuels me that's what you know as I
as I become alive I mean this winter you
know it as the warm weather comes you we
all feel like doing or as the farmer
it's just so much easier you know we
think again this year I have this
probably skewed vision that this is
going to be the best year Hope Springs
this has been a production of Cornell
University so I we are doing these
videos short video clips as a way to
have farmers speak to farmers and they
will be up on the Cornell climate change
cornell.edu website and we're hoping to
engage other cooperative extension
educators around the state to go out and
do the you know talk to their farmers
and and the farmers that they work with
and capture some of more of these videos
so that you know we're not the ones out
there preaching to farmers but they can
talk to themselves and these are some of
the resources that we have available
that there were fact sheets out in the
front and with that we're going to have
a conversation I think
you
you I guess I admitted I was an
entomologist earlier I'll make a few
assumptions that the new conditions
whether it's that or aggravating pest in
general so if we have a similar set of
circumstances then I would be surprised
if it happens again that's the best time
you know obviously I can't predict the
weather but it's these unusual wealth
wet spells cold spells whatever
interacting together and that's
sometimes it's just like I mentioned the
bark beetles you know just perfect and
insect populations take off it could
also be I don't think that's migratory
but I mean we're also having new storm
fronts come through that also bring in
pest yes Larry well I guess is on
everyone hear me yeah it's it's always
been a challenge I think communicating
with with consumers there seems to be in
a growing disconnect between the farming
community and the rest of humanity
especially as there's fewer and fewer
farmers but one thing I did notice last
year with the hurricane being that we
had such extensive damage in Orange
County the local community and consumers
really really took notice of you know
what we were going through and you know
they did a number of community events
they did a sort of a local farm aid and
community and I think they started out
with the goal of raising $20,000 by the
twentieth of whatever month was and they
ended up raising just over a hundred
thousand and they had a big event sort
of an educational event where the
community could come in you know talk
directly to farmers did you know various
exhibits setups I think it took a vet
like that or consumers at least locally
took notice of what what the farmers in
the area we're going through but yeah
it's
it's well there you know the frustration
of trying to communicate our problems
and not only our problems but how our
produce gets to the shelf and you know
even though we have a severe shortage
locally it's always going to be there in
a supermarket and and also there's seems
to be one thing I did notice you know
there's a Smith out there that all
farmers get subsidies and crop insurance
i was talking to somebody you know they
mentioned crop insurance they said well
don't you have crop insurance as well
yes i do say well did you get anything
from that I said yeah we received about
like 80,000 from crop insurance he said
wow that's quite a bit of money I said
yeah but our seed bill alone was 120,000
so this is very and you know that was a
shock to them so I I think no it's
challenge Jenny I don't know I know we
were we were pretty careful when the
frost first came not to say too much to
the papers cuz you never know the extent
of the damage and you don't want people
to write off the farm markets and not to
come so we actually were pretty
conservative and how much we told that
story and just as a side note my parents
were out in Washington state about a
month ago and that's the number one
apple producing state in the US and they
were just delighted out there because
they're filling into our markets they
were just dancing around with joy but
it's not entirely bad we do have a food
system that can can handle the
variability and the different you know
the climates and the different geography
and we don't have to go hungry but it is
a little scary for next year's markets I
ones I don't worry about it because of
course I do I think every farmer worries
about it but you know like you're saying
like i mentioned diversification i think
particularly with the more extremes and
whether the more you can diversify
yourself you spread that risk out a
little bit another word
I plant fewer acres of the more
intensive crops such as onions and
squash I can grow corn or soybeans
there's a little bit less input costs
there plus you don't have the labor
aspect of it and I think you know with
today's grain prices those crops have
been a little bit more profitable than
they have been in the past so I think
diversification is part of that but i
think you know as any farmer knows you
have to you have to be willing to accept
brisk because if if you didn't you while
you wouldn't be in this business I know
years ago my my grandmother was a great
cross stitcher and she she did this one
sampler and said if you think there's
gambling in Las Vegas just try growing
onions all around the borders they had
thrips and disease and all the different
things that can that can I can affect
the yoni drop so r it that's part of the
game I guess okay um I don't know if I
have a good answer I I guess it's true i
think it's becoming more and more
capital-intensive all the time and
there's always new technology we have an
electronic defects order that picks out
apples with marks you know spots on them
now on the packing line electronically
which is pretty cool but it's also
pretty expensive and we also have a or
we would like to get a
half-a-million-dollar internal defects
order that shines a light through every
Apple and sees if there's browning on
the inside that's a pretty expensive
price tag and at some point I think
it'll become just something we have to
have to market our you know certain
crops in the springtime when there's a
risk of internal browning after
long-term storage and customers will
just expect that we you know that we're
able to detect that so it's pretty scary
I mean I think it's one reason we really
need a strong crop insurance program I
know it's you know it's not always
enough but it's at least it keeps you
from having to dig out of quite such a
big hole because you can't
word you know next year we want to
invest in the next thing we don't want
to dig out of last year's hole so you
know you're dealing with insurance
program or you have to take the first
fifty percent of the loss so that's I
mean yeah he'd be crazy if you bought an
insurance program like that for your car
or your house because it just just going
to work you know I think you know maybe
crop insurance has come a long way but i
think it probably has a long way to go
yet before it's an effective tool you
know like for onions we buy crop
insurance because if you don't have
insurance you don't qualify for any type
of disaster aid should that come down
the line you know I mentioned you yep
take the first fifty percent of loss you
can buy up at substantially higher
premiums but that just my opinion
doesn't pay either I've talked to some
growers one year I know I talked to one
grower the payment he received in covers
premium so it yeah how was that I was
that an effective tool I'm not sure I
think even though I wouldn't like to
spend the extra money we might have to
just to ease the variability just like
if you were to have a fire you know you
by fire insurance every year but
hopefully never have a fire I I don't
know why I sure wouldn't want to pay
sixty percent more because it's already
pretty expensive but I think I think we
might have to either that or ask farm
credit to capitalize losses you know in
the years when they I guess you can do
it either way maybe depending on your
banker well I know a number of years ago
I was reading an article somewhere and
the they're trying to make the point
that one way or another consumers are
going to have to pay more for their food
whether they pay more at a grocery store
or they pay I continue to pay higher
subsidies because you know I said that
the capital that goes into agriculture
these days is you know pretty intense
and that then again goes back to the
disconnect between consumers and farmers
a lot of consumers just don't understand
what it what it takes to
grow cropper to produce food these days
um I I think my parents and I usually
see pretty eye to eye on it actually we
just fixed a fixed our interest rates
and a couple of our bigger loans and we
were pretty much in agreement about that
you know we try to manage some risk and
leave some you know leave some variable
on the interest rates but then on the
cropped crop side to you know you grab
my crop insurance but it's still a risky
business so I guess we just look at the
benefit that we could have from from
yeah I'm trying to mitigate some of the
risk and then the cost of doing that
yeah i think you know perception of risk
kind of varies not only throughout
generations but also throughout
individuals because I remember taking
farm management and college you know
talking about how you know is the older
generation progresses they get less
willing to take on risk or as a younger
generation is more willing I in case my
father I'm not so sure that's true he's
still he's still willing to roll the
dice every year and I know he's he's
always been forward thinking and looking
ahead to next year and I know over the
years he's probably made several
sacrifices to you know keep us going
probably for my benefit so and you know
like Jenny mentioned it's important to
have a good working relationship you
know we talked constantly discuss these
things so it's I I think it varies a lot
between businesses and between
individuals we try to work out all the
numbers and then take a look at it and
make a decision I'm glad that my parents
still make some of those decisions
they're kind of tough one
yeah it's sort of an interesting to be I
don't know oh absolutely I you know
there's I don't think anyone's going to
argue that we're not seeing more
extremes and weather because we
certainly are whether you know you you
believe that's due to global warming
climate change or if it just seems to be
a cycle and a much larger macro sense I
think there's still a lot of debate
there but yeah and we need to continue
to have that debate because you know
whether or not climate change is real or
how much of it is man-made I think it's
it's certainly having an impact on
agriculture and I think you know we're
gonna have to respond to it in some way
I don't know we're going to have
electric tractors but I think just
agriculture in general is getting more
efficient you feel costs are going up so
of course we're going to burn look for
ways to burn less anyway yeah i think
the lab most farmers are driven to be
efficient by nature just you notice save
on costs I also worry that if we have a
lot of regulations imposed on us about
climate change that that we will be less
able to compete with the rest of the
world and like like you were saying
before you know Mexico and China they'll
backfill the food industry they'll
they'll keep the grocery store shelves
full and probably what they're doing
won't be as environmentally sound is
what we were doing before so we just we
have to be very careful what we impose
on our farmers I think but that said I I
mean there's maybe things we should be
doing but maybe it should be more on an
encouragement level than regulatory we
actually had a farm three hours to the
north of us when I was a little girl my
parents did because McIntosh grow better
up north but we struggled because
transporting them back down without
bruising was was really difficult so we
we sold the farm after a few years I
think
but yeah they we thought about that and
now we're just Terry McIntosh out but we
found a new a new strain that grows
better the Ruby Mac but when we've
talked we haven't ever talked really too
much about doing that again because we
tried it the one time when we've talked
about relocating it's been more
discussion about labor than about
climate change yeah that that's I think
probably does make some sense diversify
geographically to farm in various
locations however from a management side
he gets to be be very difficult you know
if you're you know I've no one grower
ease this year I guess he's growing some
squash down on a Dominican Republic so
he's flying back and forth and I just
can't imagine the headaches and the
costs associated with some of that I
mean certainly there's advantages but
it's it's a tough thing to do it's
enough trying to handle one operation in
one country you try and spread that out
okay thank you all and let's give on
round of applause to our panel
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu